right it's not bad one it is not a bad
day tonight not at all so our daughter's
three but still date nights are few and
far between Backstreet Boy AJ McLean and
his wife Rachelle hits the 50 shades of
black carpet for a little mommy daddy
time most parents don't they should
because it actually you know just keeps
that marriage going strong we have the
best marriage anyways and it the best
baby girl - she's coming from some
strong musical genes that you think got
a singer on your hands I think we do
she's definitely not shy she loves to
sing she loves to dance
she loves all of my music I mean whether
it's backstreet or it's solo which has
been great except her one of her
favorite songs is actually called sex
which is a little weird
she doesn't really know that it's about
that thank God but it's a little awkward
for me you know just like Daddy play
that song sex oh my god no
AJ's little girl ava has some new
material to look forward to VSB is hard
at work on their next album we're
actually going back to old backstreet
more of that pop R&B a little bit more
grown up little bit more sexy actually
so for all the ladies up there we're
definitely we're all grown men this last
album for inner world like this was more
grown-up talking about being fathers now
we're kind of talking about being you
know just men you know so hopefully our
fans enjoy it